CAN YOU HEAR ME AREA OKAY VERY
GOOD.
OKAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE TODAY. AS A JOINT AUTHORED
WITH MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ROB BONTA.
MISTER BONTA AS WE KNOW WAS
ABSENT TODAY BUT I'M HAPPY TO
PRESENT ON HIS BEHALF AND WE
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS TO ADD THE FIVE YEAR
SUNSET PROVISION TO EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE.
THE HOMEOWNERSHIP SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS WILL ALLOW CALIFORNIANS
TO ACHIEVE HOMEOWNERSHIP BY
ALLOWING FIRST TIME HOMEBUYERS
TO SAVE FOR THE COSTS OF THEIR
FIRST TIME HOME PURCHASE. BY
USING A NEWLY CREATED TAX
ADVANTAGED SAVINGS ACCOUNT
SIMILAR TO A FIVE TWENTY NINE
COLLEGE SAVINGS ACCOUNT.
HOMEOWNERSHIP IS MORE THAN JUST
A SAFE ROOF OVER ONE'S HEAD ONE
ACHIEVABLE HOMEOWNERSHIP IS A
POWERFUL TOOL FOR ECONOMIC
MOBILITY AND IS THE SINGLE
GREATEST INVESTMENT SOME CAN
MAKE IN THEIR LIFETIME.
BUT WITH THE SOARING COSTS OF
HOMES IN CALIFORNIA THAT REALITY
IT'S OUT OF REACH FOR MANY
CALIFORNIANS.
WITH THIS BILL WE WILL ENSURE
THERE ARE MILLENNIALS AND MIDDLE
CLASS FAMILIES HAVE THE ABILITY
TO PLANT ROOTS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
POSSESS REAL FINANCIAL EQUITY.
AND USE OUR TALENTS TO ADVANCE
AND IMPROVE OUR STATE.
WE HAVE WORKED HARD FOR THREE
YEARS TO GET THIS BILL TO WHERE
IT IS TODAY AND I'M PROUD TO SEE
THE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THIS
ISSUE.
THANKFUL THAT THANK YOU AND I'M
WITH ME I.
SELECT INTRODUCED.
THANK YOU KEITH ON HER BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION WHAT GREATER TOOL
THEN EMPOWERING INDIVIDUALS TO
GO OUT AND SAVE MONEY TO
PURCHASE THEIR OWN HOME TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE AMERICAN DREAM
PROVIDE FOR THEIR FAMILIES.
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU DITION WITNESSES
AND SO FORTH.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS ACCORDING JONES
ON THE CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION
LEAGUE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEN ON WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE MISTER STEINORTH
MAJORITY OF QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
TO HAVE ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MISSION SPEAK ON THE SUN.
SEEING NONE MISTER STEINORTH YOU
DON'T CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE WHEN YOU HAVE
A QUORUM. THANK YOU AND LET ME
READ THE AMENDMENTS.
THAT YOU'VE AGREED TO ADDS A
FIVE YEAR SUNSET AND THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS IT
WILL TAKE THAT UP AS SOON AS WE
GET A QUORUM. EXCELLENT THANK
YOU A SECOND BILL IS FILE ITEM
NINE AB TWENTY NINE NINETY NINE.
THAT'S ME TOO.
ALRIGHT.
I'M GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN FIRST THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT AB TWENTY
NINE NINETY NINE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLYMAN ROB
BONTA.
FIRST THE AUTHOR IS COMMITTED TO
ACCEPT ALL THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS WHICH WILL BE TAKEN
UP IN ASSEMBLY HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY NINE NINETY NINE WOULD
CREATE A TAX CREDIT TO
INCENTIVIZE THE DONATION OF LAND
TO A NONPROFIT HOUSING DEVELOPER
FOR THE PURPOSE OF MAKING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
MORE AFFORDABLE.
AB TWENTY NINE NINETY NINE IS
ONE MORE TOOL WE CAN PROVIDE
HELP EASE THE HOUSING CRISIS.
WE ALL RECOGNIZE CALIFORNIA'S
NOT BUILT ENOUGH HOUSING TO
SUPPORT ITS POPULATION. AND H.
C. D. ESTIMATES WE PRODUCE LESS
THAN HALF OF THE NEW UNITS
NEEDED OVER THE LAST DECADE.
THIS BILL WOULD CREATE A TAX
CREDIT INCENTIVE FOR ANYONE TO
DONATE LAND TO A NONPROFIT
HOUSING DEVELOPER AND EXCHANGE
RECEIVE A TWENTY FIVE PERCENT
TAX CREDIT BASED ON THE FAIR
MARKET VALUE OF THE LAND.
THIS TAX CREDIT PROGRAM WOULD
HAVE A TEN MILLION DOLLAR CAP
PER FISCAL YEAR AND A FIVE YEAR
SUNSET.
THE LAND DONATED MUST HAVE A
FIFTY FIVE YEAR DEED RESTRICTION
TO INSURE THE UNITS BUILT ON THE
LAND REMAIN AFFORDABLE.
THANK YOU AND ON AND ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR VOTE I
SHOULD HAVE KEEP DONE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PARTICIPATION TO
WITNESS.
THANK YOU KEEP THEM ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION AGAIN ASKING FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS IMPORTANT
BILL EMPOWERING INDIVIDUALS TO
GO OUT AND FIND AND BE ABLE TO
AFFORD. THE FIRST AND NEW HOMES
IS CRITICAL TO AMERICAN BEFORE
IT WOULD ASK FOR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU DISH AWARENESS IS IN SUPPORT.
SEEN ON WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
BRING IT TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK
ON THE SIDE.
SEEING NONE MISTER STEINORTH
WOULD LIKE CLOSE AGAIN
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
WHEN YOU HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU
AGAIN WILL TAKE THAT UP WHEN WE
DO HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU. NEXT
AUTHOR I SEE MR THURMAN.
I MISS IT THIRTEEN YOU OUT FILE
ITEM SIX AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY
MAY BEGIN TO TURN THINGS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
NINE TWENTY A BILL ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF BERKELEY. THAT WOULD
ALLOW THE VOTERS THERE TO DECIDE
IF THEY WANT TO INCREASE TAXES
TO FUND ADDITIONAL SERVICES.
IT PASS
A VOTERS SO WOULD INCREASE THEIR
SALES TAX TO BE NO MORE UP MORE
THAN NINE POINT SEVEN. FIVE
PERCENT NATIONAL POINT FIVE
PERCENT THE CITY OF BERKELEY
NEEDS LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY FOR
INCREASED TO THE CURRENT
TRANSACTION AND USES TAX. IN
THIS DECREASE WOULD SURPASS THE
TWO PERCENT STATUTORY LIMIT.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS GRANTED
SEVERAL EXEMPTIONS TO THE TO
PERCENT CAP INCLUDING THE
SEVERAL COUNTIES TO ALLOW
ADDITIONAL COUNTY Y.
TRANSACTIONS AND YOU STAFF
TRANSPORTATION. PURPOSES THE
CITY OF BERKELEY IS FACING A
MAJOR HOMELESS CHALLENGE THAT
THAT IS UNIQUE TO ITS BORDERS
AND THESE FUNDS WILL BE USED TO
HELP. THOSE PROBLEMS
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF BERKLEY
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
TO GIVE THE VOTERS A CHANCE TO
DECIDE IF THEY WISH TO INCREASE
THEIR OWN TAX RATE.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY TODAY IS
NICKELODEON LUKA ON BEHALF OF
MERE AIR GAIN IN THE CITY OF
BERKLEY I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'LL BE BRIEF MY NAME
IS NICHOLAS CAM HERE BEHALF OF
THE BERKELEY MARRIAGES HERE
AGAIN I WANT THINKS ONLY MEMBER
THURMOND FULL SUPPORT AND HELP
ON THIS BILL. AS HE SAID AB
TWENTY NINE TWENTY WILL CREATE A
STATUTORY WAIVER OF THE CURRENT
THAT TRANSACTIONS AND USE TAXES
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE CITY OF
BERKELEY WE'RE NOT ASKING. FOR A
TAX INCREASE ONLY TO INCREASE TO
INCREASE THE CAPITAL OF THE
VOTERS DECIDE THESE FUNDS WILL
GO TOWARDS HOMELESSNESS MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND POLICE
RETENTION. WITH THAT WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE.
SAYING THAT WOULD LIKE TO CLONE
POLKADOT QUIXTAR.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING FORWARD
THIS GREAT FILM.
IT SEEMS WE HAVE A QUORUM I'LL
MOVE.
WE ARE EXPERTS.
FAIR QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. FELT WOULD LIKE
GROWTH NEVER WANT TO DISAGREE
WITH THAT WITH DOCTOR QUIRK I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THAT MAKES TWO OF US WE HAVE A
FORMAL.
IT'S A MOTIONS THEN TAKE A VOTE
THANK YOU MANAGER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
AND MOVING A FILE ITEM THREE AB
TWENTY THREE FIFTY FIVE MISTER
TING WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY FIVE WILL
PROHIBIT COMPANIES THAT CONTRACT
OR SUBCONTRACT TO BUILD
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S BORDER WALL.
FROM BENEFITING FROM THE
FOLLOWING STATE EXPENDITURES
MANUFACTURING RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT EQUIPMENT EXEMPTION.
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATE ENERGY
INVESTMENT TRANSPORTATION
FINANCING AUTHORITY EXCLUSION
NEW EMPLOYMENT CREDIT CALIFORNIA
COMPETES TAX CREDIT IN
CALIFORNIA RESEARCH CREDIT.
THE WALL AS WE KNOW IT'S A VERY
DIVISIVE PROJECT WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
IN OUR COUNTRY WHETHER IT'S
ROADS OR TRANSIT. AYE AYE
PERCENT BELIEVE THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT WASTE OF TAXPAYER
DOLLARS AND I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
CALIFORNIANS SHOULD HAVE TO FOR
ANY PART OF THAT BILL.
WITHOUT WE ARE LESS LIKELY AS
TRIBAL.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
BRIAN HOW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS.
I LIKE TO START MY TESTIMONY BY
REMINDING YOU ALL THAT THIS IS
THE TEACHER APPRECIATE FOOD
APPRECIATION WEEK.
SO I AND WE ARE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE A SUPPORT OF THE
SPELL.
OUR OUR UNION.
MET OVER THE WEEKEND KNOW WHERE
A LITTLE LATE HAD.
BUT WE OVERWHELMINGLY VOTED TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AYE AS YOU
KNOW SEVENTY THREE PERCENT OF
CALIFORNIA'S OPPOSED BORDER WALL.
SIX PERCENT OF ALL OF AMERICANS
PUTS BORDER WALL HOWEVER ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT MY MEMBERSHIP
OPPOSE THIS BULLET POINT WHAT SO.
ON A VERY MUCH APPRECIATED
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SMITH A QUORUM HAVE THE TELFORD
A TAX REFORM ASSOCIATION ALWAYS
HAPPY TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT A
BILL IN THIS COMMITTEE LIKE TO
THINK MISTER TING FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND PROTECTING
CALIFORNIA'S TAX DOLLARS
THINKING.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
YOU KNOW WHAT JUDGE BOTH.
I'M JUST AGAIN NOW.
WE BELIEVE THAT CALIFORNIA'S TAX
DOLLARS SHOULD BE SPENT ON
INFRASTRUCTURE BUOY ONE OF THE
SUPPORT OTHER DIFFERENT TYPES OF
INFRASTRUCTURE EXPENDITURES.
WITHOUT RESPECT FAST FOR AYE
VOTE.
I WE HAVE A QUORUM ABOUT
THINKING
.
I MEAN IF I ATTEND AB THIRTY
FIFTY SEVEN.
HIS QUICKSILVER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS A. B.. THIRTY FIFTY
SEVEN ADDRESSES A TECHNICAL
ISSUE IN THE STATE'S REVENUE AND
TAXATION CODE THAT WILL HELP
EXPEDIA GRANTS AND LOANS FOR
WATER SYSTEM. AS NONPROFIT
ENTITIES MITCHELL WATER MUTUAL
DICTIONARY CATION COMPANIES IN
CALIFORNIA ARE CURRENTLY ABLE TO
OBTAIN TAX EXEMPTION AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL BUT THERE'S NO
SIMILAR RELIEF. FOR IN
CALIFORNIA.
LAW AND ORDER TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
CERTAIN STATE GRANTS AND LOANS
DEDICATED TO SMALL WATER SYSTEMS
SUCH AS MUTUAL WATER COMPANIES A
COMPANY MUST ATTEST TO ITS TAX
EXEMPT STATUS NO CALIFORNIA
AUTHORITY APPLIES THAT ENABLES.
YOU TO WATER COMPANIES TO OBTAIN
THAT STATUS AT THE STATE LEVEL.
BY AMENDING CURRENT CALIFORNIA
REP. REVENUE AND TAX CODE TO
CONFORM TO THE TAX EXEMPTION
PROVIDED UNDER THE INTERNAL
REVENUE CODE AB THREE ZERO FIVE
SEVEN WILL HELP THE STATE
EXPEDIA A GRANTS TO HELP SMALL
WATER SYSTEMS MAKE IMPROVEMENTS.
AND CONSOLIDATE HERE TO EXPLAIN
OUR TO REPRESENT AND IS
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION MUTUAL
WATER COMPANIES MISTER JIM.
CM BUT CHAMP OF CHAMPA AND
MISTER I DON ORTEGA ARE.
WELCOME LACKEY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OF PARK SEVEN THANK YOU FOR.
OFFERING THIS BILL I'M JIM
CHAMPA GENERAL COUNSEL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF MUTUAL
WATER COMPANIES AB THIRTY FIFTY
SEVEN SEEKS TO ADDRESS AN ISSUE
THAT HAS BEEN A PROBLEM OVER THE
PAST FOUR OR FIVE YEARS.
PRIMARILY IMPACTING SMALL WATER
SYSTEMS THAT OUR MUTUAL WATER
COMPANIES
EACH WATER COMPANIES ARE DEFINED
IN THE CORPORATION'S CODE IN THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES CODE. AS WATER
COMPANIES THAT PROVIDE WATER TO
THEIR SHAREHOLDERS AT COST AT
COST ISN'T DEFINED IN THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES CO DEMEAN WITHOUT A
PROFIT SO BY DEFINITION. THESE
ARE NONPROFIT ENTITIES I'M THAT
ARE GRANTED TAX EXEMPTION UNDER
THE INTERNAL REVENUE CODE. UP
THIS BILL WILL SEEK TO ALIGN
CALIFORNIA LAW WITH FEDERAL LAW
WITH RESPECT TO THAT TAX
EXEMPTION FOR MUTUAL WATER
COMPANIES. ON IT WILL FREE UP
MONEY FOR THOSE SMALL SYSTEMS BE
USED.
FOR SYSTEM IMPROVEMENTS
OPERATING COSTS AND ALSO FOR.
INCREASING RESERVES AS MANDATED
UNDER AB FIFTY FOUR.
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
OTHER WITNESSES THAT SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
RUN DAVIS ON BEHALF OF MR
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
SPORTS.
THANK YOU.
WHEN THIS IS IN OPPOSITION.
I'VE SEEN ARENA QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FOR THE COMMITTEE
DUCTWORK.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING OUT THIS.
BILL WHICH WILL HELP.
THE SMALL MOSTLY RURAL
DISTRICTS REALLY APPRECIATE IT
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. NO.
MS CREEK WHICH I CLOSE. IT I
JUST WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT AND I DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT TO WE HAVE OUR
WATER WIZARD IF WE WANT TO CALL
IN THAT DEATH ADAN ORTEGA WHO
HAPPENS TO LIVE IN FULLERTON AS
WELL AND HAS BEEN WORKING UP AND
DOWN. THE STATE WITH SMALL WATER
COMPANIES ARE NOW TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THEY CAN MAXIMIZE ANY TYPES
OF OF AVAILABILITY OUT THERE AS
FAR AS GRANTS AND SO FORTH.
GREAT WHAT THINK YOU THIS THIS
WAS.
NARROW BILL AND THE
RECOMMENDATION WHEN WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS AND WE HAVE NO
MINUTES I THINK YOU.
.
WE HAVE A FORMAL VOTE. THANK YOU.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM SEVEN.
AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY TWO
DOCTORS CHOI WOULD YOU LIKE TO
OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THE
MEMBERS.
OF LIKE CHIU.
START BY THANKING THE CHAIR AND
THE.
COMMITTEE STAFF LOOK TO WERE
OUT WORKING FOR WORKING WITH ME
DOCTOR AND I THINK THAT ACTUALLY
CAN I HOLD YOU FOR ONE SECOND WE
HAVE A CORPSMAN BEFORE WE LOSE
IT BECAUSE WE HAVE TROUBLE
GETTING ONE AROUND HERE.
HOW CAN WE HAVE WOULD YOU MIND
IF WE HAVE THE CLERK CALLED THE
ROLL?
BURKE.
BROUGH HERE.
CARILLO.
CHIU.
GRAY.
THEY'RE MCCARTY MELENDEZ. MULLIN
QUIRK HERE VOEPEL.
HAVE A CLEAR PATH.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTS UP
TAYEH CONTINUING ON OUR OUR OWN
I'M ONCE AGAIN THAT I THINK IT'S
CHAIR AND THE.
A COMMITTEE STAFF MEMBERS HAVE
WORKING NOW WITH ME AND ON MY
STAFF FLORA ON THIS BILL. OUT OF
LOOKS UP THE AMENDMENTS ARE
SUGGESTED UP BY YOUR COMMITTEE
UP ANALYSIS.
AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY TO APPEAR
THAT.
I HAVE. ENTITLED AS.
Y. COMING BUSINESSES TO
CALIFORNIA A PROVIDES AYE AT.
THE TAX CREDIT OFFICE SEVENTEEN
POINT FIVE PERCENT OF FOR
BUSINESSES. ADEPT MOVE TOUR OR
EXPAND THE IN CALIFORNIA.
IN NOT TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN D.
OUT LEGISLATURE.
OFFERED <c.green> SEMINAR SEVENTEEN</c>
POINT FIVE PERCENT TAX CREDIT OF
WAGES TO PAY TO LACKEY MARTIN
AND UP NORTH OR BY BORN OF
BRAHMIN.
TO INCENTIVIZE STEM A TO LOCATE
THEIR LARGE MANUFACTURING
FACILITIES OUT IN CALIFORNIA.
AB YEAH TWENTY NINE THIRTY TWO
WOULD STICK TO EXTEND THIS A TAX
CREDIT. TO THE BORDER OR. A
BUSINESS COMMUNITY IF.
THIS A TAX CREDITS ARE ARE GOOD
ENOUGH FOR TO HIS SO TO
COMPANIES SAW.
Y. ONTO A GOOD ENOUGH FOR FOR
ALL BUSINESSES ARE A TO CONSIDER
EXPANDING IN CALIFORNIA.
BY INCREASING THE NUMBER OF A
BUSINESS HISA OPERATING OUT IN
THE STATE.
THE JOB. THAT WOULD BE CREATED
AND THE REVENUE.
WOULD BE GENERAL.
WOULD BE INCREASED A AND.
ASSET TADALISTA ON FOR NEW
GROWTH. IN THE ECONOMY. A. B.
TWENTY NINE THIRTY TWO OUR IS SO
UNNECESSARY ACTIVE FOR TACKLING
THE STATE SO FINANCIAL
UNCERTAINTY.
TODAY A.
MISTER OUR SON LOUISE I A
REPRESENTATIVE FOR FROM THE
NATIONAL FEDERATION OF
INDEPENDENT BUSINESSES. WAS
SUPPOSED TO OUR JOIN ME.
TO.
A SUPPORT.
DISPEL LA HOWEVER AT THE LAST
MINUTE UNAVOIDABLE LA ARMED
CONFLICT OR HAS A RECENT AND SO
I HE ASKED ME TO OF CHAU DO
SUPPORT ALL FOR. NFL NOT AND
THEREFORE I'D BE OUT WITH THE
OUR COMMITTEE TODAY AND I'LL LET
YOU KNOW THAT THE.
HERE DIAZ AMENDING OUR.
LETTERPRESS SAPORTA.
AS THE BILL MOVES FOR WHAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WE ARE I'VE
WHAT.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION WE HAVEN'T HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONNECT WITH THE
AUTHOR BECAUSE OFFICE YET BUT WE
WILLBE MOVING TO OPPOSE THE
BILL AS WRITTEN. UNLIKE DE AYE
LOUGHEED BILL WHICH SHOULD
MENTION PREVIOUSLY IT'S
EXTRAORDINARILY BROAD AND AT A
TIME WHEN THE STATE HAS A THREE
POINT EIGHT. RECORD SETTING A
LOW OF UNEMPLOYMENT RATES AND
WE'RE NOT SURE THE NEED FOR THIS
PARTICULAR BILL AND IT
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE STATE IS
STRUGGLING TO FIND.
INDIVIDUALS TO WORK AND HIGHLY
SKILLED JOBS AND LOOKING TO
INVEST.
STATES FUNDS MORE APPROPRIATELY
INTO THE PROGRAMS THAT WOULD
ENSURE STUDENTS ARE PREPARED TO
WORK IN THOSE JOBS
SO AT THIS TIME WE OPPOSED THANK
YOU.
Q. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE DOT QUIRK.
YES WE ALREADY HAVE A PROGRAM
AND WHICH IS.
DIRECTED.
.
IN A MORE SPECIFIC WAY THAN
YOURS IS IT'S GONNA BE. REVISED
IN THE YEAH BUDGET THIS YEAR I
SUPPORT THAT PROGRAM AND I I
DON'T THINK YOUR PROGRAM IS HAS
DIRECTED SO I WON'T BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY THANK.
MOVE THE BILL. OUT OF REACH OF A.
THE MOTION OF THE SECOND.
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSER TO CHOI.
NO THANK YOU.
THIS BIT IS A SIMPLY. TO EXPAND
OUR POWER. OF BUSINESSES AND TO
CREATE A MORE JOBS SO WHEN NEW
BUSINESSES TO MOVE IN WITH THE
TWENTY OR MORE EMPLOYEES. WHAT
EXISTING BUSINESSES? ARE ADDING
TWENTY.
OUR OR MORE EMPLOYEES TO THINK
ABOUT THE REST OF THE YEAH.
.
A.
T. PAY LOWER.
AT THAT WOULD BE CREATED THE
MOST OF THE PEOPLE WHO WOULD BE.
PAYING THEIR TAX.
SO ARE A STATE REVENUE IS COULD
NOT ONLY GO UP PART RATHER THAN
COSTING DOES.
DOES TO STATE SO I DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE FROM MY COMMON.
SOMEONE THESIS ON OUR ADDITIONAL
REVENUE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
STATE TO BUY ALLOWING A THE
BUSINESS TO A MOVIE IN WHAT
EXPAND IN THE STATE'S ALL. AYE
ARE.
AS FOR YOU I'VE.
.
SO YOU SAID YOU'RE ACCEPTING
AMENDMENTS IT'S OF THE
AMENDMENTS ARE TO SHORTEN SUNSET
FROM SEVEN TO FIVE YEARS AND
THERE'S TO FTP PROTECT LOCAL
MOMENTS TO REFINE THE LANGUAGE
IS LISTED ON PAGE FIVE OF THE
ANNOUNCES.
AB ANGIE DOT THE CLERK BUT.
IS HIGHLY PROBABLE.
BURKE.
BURKE AYE BRO. BRO AYE CARILLO.
CREEL AYE CHIU.
NOT VOTING GRAY AYE GRAY AYE
MCCARTY. MELENDEZ MULLIN QUIRK
NO QUIRK NO VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I.
BECAUSE IT'S WHAT. AT THAT BILLS
ON CALL YOU NEED ONE MORE VOTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I WOULD IF I AM TO AB TWENTY
SIXTY SIX MISTER STONE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO OPEN.
THIS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
HOPING.
THIS RACE IS.
JOINT AUTHOR ON THIS BILL. AND
SO IS HOPING THAT THAT YOU HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE MAYBE
SHE'LL SHOW UP WE'VE BEEN TRYING
TO REACH HER. TO GET HER TO COME
TEST TEST SITES WELL BY ONE.
DECLARE THAT WE'RE HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENT THAT'S
LISTED IN. THE ANALYSIS WHICH
DELAYS THE IMPLEMENTATION PER
THE FRANCHISE TASK TAX BOARD.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT BUILDS
ON THE EXISTING EARNED INCOME
TAX CREDIT PROGRAM WHICH IS ONE
OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT PROGRAMS
FOR BEING ABLE TO MOVE PEOPLE?
OUT OF POVERTY. THIS.
THANK YOU THIS WOULD EXTEND THE
BILL TO YOUNG ADULTS AGES
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR.
LOW INCOME WORKING SENIORS OVER
THE AGE OF SIXTY FIVE AS WELL AS
INDIVIDUALS WITH IT AYE ENDS.
DAY.
TAX IN.
TAXPAYER INFORMATION INFORMATION
NUMBERS HAS OPPOSE OF SEARED
NUMBERS. AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR ITEMS.
AND WE HAVE COUPLE WITNESSES TO
TALK ABOUT THE BENEFITS OF THEIR
INCOME TAX CREDIT AND THAT THE
FACT THAT WE NEED TO GET INTO
THESEPOPULATIONS AND HELP SERVE
THEM AS WELL.
GOOD AFTERNOON THOUGH CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE M.
JUDY DARNELL VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED WAYS A CALIFORNIA.
A MEMBERSHIP ASSOCIATION OF
THIRTY ONE LOCAL UNITED WAYS
AROUND THAT.
STATE MANY OF WHICH YOU ARE
PARTNER WITH REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT. A WE ARE PROUD SPONSOR
TWENTY SIXTY SIX AND WE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE THE CALLEA
TO SEE FOR A FEW MOMENTS.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
LAST YEAR OF TO EXPAND THE EITC
TO THE.
SELF EMPLOYED CALIFORNIANS
HOWEVER THERE IS MORE WORK TO DO
THIS BILL DOES IT UNITED WAYS A
LARGE COALITION OF CALLIE I TO
SEE ADVOCATES BELIEVE THAT IF
YOU WORK. YOU PAY YOUR TAXES YOU
FILE YOUR TAX RETURNS AND MEET
THE INCOME ELIGIBILITY
GUIDELINES YOU SHOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO CALLIE ITC. TWENTY
SIXTY SIX INSURERS THIS BY
EXTENDING THE CREDIT ALL LOW
INCOME WORKERS EIGHTEEN YEARS
AND OLDER THEY'RE STRUGGLING TO
GET BY. THIS WILL COVER YOUNG
ADULTS JUST STARTING OUT SENIORS
THAT ARE FORCED TO STAY IN THE
WORK FORCE OVER THE AGE OF SIXTY
FOUR. AND CERTAIN IMMIGRANT AB.
ADULTS WHO FILE THEIR. TAX
RETURNS WITH THE ITEM NUMBER.
ONE IN THREE CALIFORNIANS
STRUGGLED TO MEET BASIC LIVING
COSTS ABOUT TWICE THE OFFICIAL
POVERTY RATE. AND NINE AND TEN
ARE LED BY WORKING ADULT
ACCORDING TO OUR REAL COST
MEASURE RESEARCH.
THE POVERTY RATE AMONG SENIORS
IS OVER TWENTY PERCENT AND
GROWING. UNITED WAY.
AND OUR PARTNER.
VITA SITES AND WE KNOW FIRST
HAND WHAT A DIFFERENCE EITC
MAKES.
SO WE WANT TO CATCH.
MAKE SURE THAT CALLIE I TO SEE
HAS BEEN A GREAT SUCCESS WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT CONTINUES
TO BE A GREAT SUCCESS AND BY
STRENGTHENING IT THROUGH THE
ADDING INCLUDING THE THREE
GROUPS THAT AREN'T CURRENTLY
EXCLUDED. A WE FEEL THAT THE
ECONOMICS OF.
SECURITY ISN'T WITHIN MORE.
WORKERS REACH.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND WE
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
A GOOD AFTERNOON I'M ADAM CHECK
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SEEM TO
DISSOLVE A WITH THAT CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER RAS A CO
SPONSOR ON AB TWENTY SIXTY SIX.
I'M YOU KNOW INCLUSION I THINK
IS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE WE LOCK
OUT CALIFORNIANS BASED ON
IMMIGRATION STATUS IT NOT ONLY
SET BACK FAMILIES A COMMUNITIES
THAT REALLY DOES HURT OUR STATE.
I IMMIGRANTS MAKE UP ONE THIRD
OF OUR WORKFORCE BUT THEY'RE
ALSO PARENTS TO OVER HALF OF THE
KIDS IN OUR STATE AND AS
TAXPAYERS THEY CONTRIBUTE THREE
BILLION. AND STATE AND LOCAL
TAXES YET THE SAME TAX FILERS
WHEN THEY FALL ON HARD TIMES ARE
EXCLUDED FROM THIS CREDIT TO
KEEP A LITTLE MORE OF WHAT THEY
EARN IN ORDER TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
WE CAN REMOVE THESE EXCLUSIONS
IN TWENTY SIXTY SIX BY
HARNESSING EXISTING MECHANISMS
LIKE THE FEDERALLY ASSIGNED
TAXPAYER IDENTIFICATION NUMBER
KNOWN AS A NIGHT TEN. IT WAS
CREATED IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX
BY THE IRS SO THAT THE IRS HAD
WAY TO PROCESS.
TAX CLAIMS FOR INDIVIDUALS THAT
DID NOT HAVE A SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER AND THE USE OF THE A TENS
ALLOWS THE FOR IRIS TO BRING IN
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS EVERY SINGLE
YEAR AND FACT. AND TWENTY
SIXTEEN THE R. S. THAT'S WHY I
TEN FILERS PAID OVER TWENTY FOUR
BILLION AND FEDERAL TAXES AND
CALIFORNIA THERE'S AN ESTIMATED
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND I TEND TAX
FILERS. AND RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
THE MAJORITY OF THESE FILERS ARE
RESIDENTS OF REGIONS WITH HIGH
AGRICULTURAL OUTPUT AND OR LARGE
SPANISH SPEAKING POPULATIONS
WHICH CERTAINLY ARE
CHARACTERISTICS THAT MATCH
NUMBER OF COUNTIES. IN OUR STATE
SO UNFORTUNATELY WHILE THE
NUMBER PROVIDES THESE
INDIVIDUALS OPPORTUNITY TO FILE
THEIR TAXES IT'S STILL INCLUDE
EXCLUDES THEM FROM THE FEDERAL
AND STATE EITC. AND SO THAT I
TEN MAY BE NEW TO THE ATC BUT
THEY'RE AN EXISTING CALIFORNIA
TAX FURTHER POPULATION FOR OVER
TWO DECADES.
IN FACT WE'VE ALREADY STARTED
HARNESSING THE OPPORTUNITY OF
THE I TEN. THROUGH.
ENTREPRENEURSHIP OPPORTUNITIES
RELATED TO MAKING SURE PEOPLE
HAVE ACCESS TO PROFESSIONAL
LICENSES AND AN EFFORT THIS YEAR
TO ALLOW ITEM HOLDERS TO APPLY
FOR LOCAL BUSINESS LIFE AND SO
THEY CAN START UP. A BUSINESS
AND SUPPORT THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES I'M CERTAINLY THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD COMMENTS IN
THE ANALYSIS I THINK DEMONSTRATE
THAT THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY. TO
STRENGTHEN OUR ANTI POVERTY
EFFORTS BUT ALSO TO IMPROVE OUR
TAX SYSTEM BY INCORPORATING
NECESSARY MECHANISMS THAT
REFLECT THE FULL BREADTH OF WHO
ARE TAX PAIN POPULATION IN
CALIFORNIA IS. ECONOMIC
INCLUSION ALLOWS US TO CONTINUE
ADVANCING ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT PARTY
AFFECTS MANY WORKERS REGARDLESS
OF THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS IN
FACT FOR HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE
HEADED BY AN UNDOCUMENTED
INDIVIDUAL. THERE ARE EARNING
APPROXIMATELY SIXTEEN THOUSAND
ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS PER YEAR SO
IT'S REALLY CRITICAL THAT AT
THIS TIME WE REALLY LOOK AT
OPPORTUNITIES TO REMOVE THESE
EXCLUSIONS. I'M FROM THE STATE
EITC AND TO BUILD THE NECESSARY
MECHANISMS FOR ALL TAX FILERS.
THIS ALSO COMES AT A REALLY
CRITICAL TIME WHEN FEDERALLY THE
GOVERNMENT IS LOOKING AT
STRIPPING AWAY ALL FORMS OF
IMMIGRATION RELIEF FOR
INDIVIDUALS SO THOSE ARE DR
POPULATIONS AS A TPS POPULATIONS.
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WILL CONTINUE
TO HAVE A FEDERAL IF I SO
SECURITY NUMBER BUT THEY WILL BE
CUT OUT OF THE EITC MOVING
FORWARD WHEN THEY LOSE THEIR
IMMIGRATION RELIEF. OUR
COMMITMENT TO ELIMINATING
POVERTY SHOULD NOT STOP AT AN
INDIVIDUAL'S IMMIGRATION STATUS
THIS AN OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD A
MORE EQUITABLE POLICY AND TO
IMPROVE THE IDC'S IMPACT AMONG
LOW INCOME WORKING FAMILIES. WE
THINK THE AUTHORS FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP AND OUR YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
SO IN MEMORY AS THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
WITH YOU THE IMPORTANCE OF AB
TWO ZERO SIX SIX.
THE KELLEY I T. C. EXTENSION
BILL.
POVERTY AFFECTS ALL OF US IT
IMPACTS OUR LOCAL ECONOMIES IN
OUR QUALITY OF LIFE.
CURRENTLY OVER FIVE POINT FIVE
MILLION PEOPLE IN THE STATE LIVE
IN POVERTY. AT APPROXIMATELY
SEVENTY NINE POINT FOUR PERCENT
OF THOSE IN POVERTY LIVE IN
FAMILIES WITH AT LEAST ONE
WORKING ADULT.
WORKING FAMILIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA ARE STRUGGLING TO
MAKE ENDS MEET AND THEREFORE
CANNOT CONTRIBUTE TO THEIR LOCAL
ECONOMY OR BUILD FINANCIAL
SECURITY. THIS CAUSES A RIPPLE
EFFECT THAT LEAVES OUR
COMMUNITIES WITHOUT THE ADEQUATE
RESOURCES AND OPPORTUNITY FOR
UPWARD ECONOMIC MOBILITY.
THE GOOD NEWS IS WE HAVE THE
POWER TO CHANGE THESE OUTCOMES
WITH THE POWER TO PUT MONEY INTO
THE POCKETS OF WORKING FAMILIES.
WHO HAVE DONE EVERYTHING RIGHT?
CAN'T GET AHEAD.
EXPANDING THE CAL.
CAL E. I. T. C. TO INCLUDE LOW
INCOME WORKING ADULTS AGED
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR LOW
INCOME WORKING SENIORS OVER THE
AGE OF SIXTY FIVE. AND LOW
INCOME WORKING IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES WITH INDIVIDUAL TAX
IDENTIFICATION NUMBERS IS THE
RIGHT MOVE FOR CALIFORNIA.
NOW IS THE TIME TO EXPAND THE
KELLY I TO SEE AND MAKE IT
INCLUSIVE AND EQUITABLE.
FOR ALL LOW INCOME WORKING
FAMILIES
THE CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT HAS A PROVEN RECORD OF
BEING ONE OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE.
POVERTY FIGHTING TOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA.
BY WORKING TO ALLEVIATE POVERTY
BY EXPANDING KELLY I TO SEE.
CALIFORNIA WILL UPLIFT THE MOST
ECONOMICALLY DISTRESSED
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE.
WE KNOW THE PROGRAM WORKS IT IS
EFFICIENT EFFECTIVE AND
EQUITABLE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MICHELLE STILL PREVENTS HE
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA VERY PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL. AND.
URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LOOK NURSING WITH CALVET
POLLUTION FOR YOU TO SPIRIT AND
A CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT.
HI TIFFANI PULLEYBLANK WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
HI SABRINA HAMMER THE CALIFORNIA
ACID BUILDING COALITION IN
SUPPORT.
KEVIN ENDS CHO FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
THING THEN QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE OF PUT EITHER OF YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
ASPIRO THAT.
I WITH THAT IS HIGHLY CALL THE
ROLL.
BURKE AYE BROUGH.
BROWN NOT VOTING CARILLO.
CREEL AYE CHIU.
GRAY AYE GRAY AYE MCCARTY
MELINDA'S.
MELINDA STOP VOTING MULLIN
MULLIN AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
VOEPEL.
THE BILL MONTHLY IT'S ON COOLEY
ME.
THAT MEANS WON MORE VOTE IT DOWN
COST THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FOR AB
TWENTY SEVEN OH THREE MISTER
MEANS WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPEN.
OKAY.
MOVE THE BILL OKAY.
SEC.
THAT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
I REALIZE THAT A MOTION A SECOND
BUT WILL JUST READ A LITTLE BIT
MORE. WILL TRY TO KEEP THIS.
KEEP THIS.
YOU KNOW QUICK RIGHT.
I'D LIKE TO START OFF BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS ON PAGE
FOUR THAT ALICE IS TO SPECIFY
THE TAXPAYER WOULD NOT RECEIVE.
THE TAX CREDIT FOR REIMBURSED
EXPENSE
AB TWENTY SEVEN AT THREE WOULD
ESTABLISH A PERSONAL INCOME TAX
CREDIT FOR HOME CARE SERVICES.
PACIFIC LEAD THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES THE MAXIMUM PERSONAL
INCOME TAX TURN UP TO FIVE
THOUSAND FOR INDIVIDUALS EARNING
A HUNDRED THOUSAND OR LESS.
THE LEGISLATURE MAY DETERMINE
THE EFFICACY OF THIS COURT AFTER
THE FOUR YEAR SUNSET DATE.
HOME CARE IS ROOTED IN THE
PRINCIPLE THAT OLDER ADULTS
SHOULD BE FREE TO AGE AT HOME
WITH THE LEVEL OF CARE THEY NEED
TO BE SAFE AND COMFORTABLE.
PRIVATE PAY HOME CARE PROVIDERS
WORK HARD TO ENSURE THEIR
CLIENTS ARE ABLE TO LIVE AS
INDEPENDENTLY AS POSSIBLE
RECEIVING A SUPPORT THEY NEED.
TO MAINTAIN A HIGH QUALITY OF
LIFE AS YOU KNOW OUR POPULATION
IS AGING RAPIDLY. I'M A MINUTE
CUT SOME OF THE STUFF OUT AND.
WITH ME TODAY'S ANNOUNCED USES
BE THIS.
UNTIL THE PROVIDE A FEW
COMMENTS.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ARE MANY
MISDIAGNOSIS IT THIS TIME I'M
THE OWNER OF PRICE TAG CARE HOME
CARE AGENCY HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
AND BEEN IN BUSINESS FOR TEN
YEARS AND WE PROVIDE A SHORT
TERM OR LONG TERM CARE FOR
FAMILIES. ABOUT TWO HUNDRED OF
THEM IN A EVERY YEAR.
AND THAT WE'RE SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL FROM OUR EXPERIENCE SENIORS
PREFERRED TO STAY AT HOME NINE
OUT OF TEN AND THEY EAT SO THEY
IN THE NEED TO REMAIN A SAFE AND
ENGAGE THAT HALL. WITH HOME CARE
SERVICES THERE'S A HUGE HUGE
IMPACT ON THE REDUCTION IN FALSE
TRIPS TO THE HOSPITAL.
COMPLIANCE WITH THEIR MEDICAL
CARE.
AND CARE GIVERS HELPS BOUGHT
CHANGES IN THEIR CONDITION THAT
THEY CONVEY TO THE FAMILY AND
THEY CONVEY TO MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS SAVING HEALTHCARE
COSTS FROM PREVENTING. ISSUES.
ADDITIONALLY HOME CARE SUPPORT
SUPPORTS THE FAMILY AT OFTEN
CASES AND AT FAMILY MEMBERS.
CARING FOR NO THE PERSON DIED
BEFORE THE WEATHER CARE FOR
BECAUSE THE STRESS AND
ENGAGEMENT AND CARE FOR THEM.
OF.
FOR THOSE AT HOME IT'S IMPORTANT
TO AVOID ISOLATION AND
DEPRESSION WHICH IS VERY COMMON.
SO LET'S WARY THOUGHT FOR
EXAMPLE TAKE A RECENT CLIENT OF
OURS MISTER JARVIS HE'S AN
EIGHTY FOUR YEAR OLD MAN WHO WAS
HIS CHARGE FROM A HOSPITAL OR
HOSPICE. HE CAME HOME BED BOUND
STUCK IN BED.
AND WITH LITTLE LIFE LEFT LEFT
IN HIM ABOUT TWO MONTHS AGO A
FAMILY WAS AROUND BUT DIDN'T
HAVE ENOUGH TIME TO HELP THEM I
SAID AS MUCH AS SHE NEEDED.
BANG GAZE TO SERVICES OF HOME
CARE.
JARVIS.
ESTABLISH A GOOD REPORT WITH
HIS CARE GIVERS HE STARTED
PLAYING CARD GAMES WITH THEM HE
STARTED TO BE ABLE TO WALK.
HE STARTED TEACHING THEM GAMES.
AND.
NO.
HE IS ENJOYING THE BEST QUALITY
OF LIFE STILL A HOSPICE.
BUT FOR THE LITTLE TIME HE HAS
LEFT IT HAS MADE HUGE IMPACT FOR
HIM AND HIS FAMILY.
THE HOME CARE SERVICES ARE
PROHIBITIVELY EXPENSIVE
UNFORTUNATELY I DO THAT. AND I
KNOW SOME PEOPLE CAN AFFORD AND
SOME DON'T THOSE ON THE HIGHER
LEVEL INCOME CAN AFFORD IT BY
THOSE IN THE VERY LOW LEVEL OF
INCOME MAYBE CAN HEAL GET HELP
FROM MEDI CAL AN IN HOME SUPPORT
SERVICES. AND THE ONCE IN THE
MIDDLE.
CANNOT SO FAR THAT'S WHAT WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE
RAINY PARKING BEHALF OF HOME
INSTEAD IS SIXTY BUSINESS SO
OWNERS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HELLO BY GOOD AFTERNOON I JUST
OF US PRINT OUT SOME IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL LIKE TO.
ABOUT MINUTES AND THEN JUST READ
THIS OFF HERE.
APPRECIATE THE OPEN ISCUSSION
AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO
YOU ABOUT MY SUPPORT FOR BILL AB
TWENTY SEVEN OH THREE.
MY GRANDMA A HUG GRANDFATHER
WASN'T ALERT ACTIVE MALE WHO
SUFFERED A GREAT DEAL TOWARD THE
END OF HIS LIFE. DUE TO AN
ACCIDENT WHERE HE WAS NOT AT
FAULT.
I NEED HOME CARE WE WERE ABLE TO
PROVIDE SOME ASK FAMILY MEMBERS.
THE REST OF THE CARE WAS DONE MY
GRAMMA AND THROUGH PRIVATE
AGENCIES.
A PRIVATE AGENCIES ARE MORE
ADEPT AT OF THE CERTAIN NEEDS
THAT ONE WOULD HAVE LIKED.
GIVING SHOWERS TRANSPORTING A
CLIENT TO DOCTORS APPOINTMENTS
AND FACILITATING OTHER A DEALS
WHICH ARE ACTIVITIES OF DAILY
LIVING.
LICENSE AGENCIES HAVE WELL
TRAINED STAFF THEIR SCREEN
BONDED AND INSURED.
OF THROUGH THE LIFE EXPERIENCE
OF SEEING MY GRANDPA STRUGGLE IN
HELPING HIM ANY WAY I COULD.
THIS DREW ME TO THE FIELD OF
CARE GIVING HIM CURRENTLY UP THE
OWNER OF. LICENSE NON MEDICAL
HOME CAREAGED DAMAGE. IN ROSEAU
AND.
I INTERVIEW PEOPLE FREQUENTLY
WHO WOULD BENEFIT FROM WHAT I
OFFER YOU THE PERSON IN THEIR
FAMILY CANNOT AFFORD THE
SERVICES IF THIS BILL PASSES IT
WOULD HELP A LOT OF PEOPLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME AND I'M A URGING YOU TO.
SUPPORT SUPPORT THE BILL AND
VOTE I.
THANKS THANK YOU FOR COMING.
WE THIS IS AN OFF OF. OUR BRAVE
IMPRESS HIM AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH SERVICES AT
HOME IN SUPPORT THINK.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION CANNELLA.
RETURN OPPOSE THE BILL YET.
.
BUT WE WILL HAVE A CONVERSATION
WITH THE OTHERS OFFICE AT THIS
POINT IT STILL READS A LITTLE
OVERLY BROAD PARTICULARLY FOR
THE POPULATIONS.
AND INCOMES LEVELS THAT SEEKS TO
SERVE.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
COUSINS ACKNOWLEDGE A MYSTERY.
YOUR QUESTION NO COMMENTS. SCENE
I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY OUT BECAUSE I
VOTE.
THAT MEANS I ONLY CALDERON.
BURKE.
BUT WE AND THE RECOMMENDATION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED
APPROPRIATIONS.
BURKE AYE BURKE AYE.
BRO. BRO I CARRILLO.
CREEL AYE CHIU.
GRAY. AYE GRAY AYE MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA.
WELL IT IS AYE MULLIN. MULLIN
AYE QUIRK NO WORK NO VOEPEL. AYE
AYE
THE BILL'S PASSED. THAT BILLOWED
OUT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY LEAKING NPA MOVE FILE ITEM.
HOLD ON LET ME CATCH AT.
LIVING.
FILE ITEM ONE A. B. NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE EIGHTY A MOTION.
MOVE THE BILL.
IN A MOTION AND A SECOND.
IS HIGHLY KALRA.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS FOR AYE AYE
BURKE I'VE WORLD. BRAILLE ARE
AYE CARILLO. BETWEEN ONE.
CARILLO AYE CHIU.
GRAY AYE AYE GRAY AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S LINDA'S
AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK NO. WORK NO
VOEPEL.
BELLA IT'S AN AIDS.
THAT BILLS OUT EIGHT TO ONE.
WELL YOU CAN GO TO NUMBER TWO.
CRANE MOVING A FILE ITEM TO AB
TWENTY SIXTY SIX WELL IF THE
KONG CALL THE ABSENTEES QUESTION
IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MCCARTY.
CURRY I.
THE BILL SO.
SO THAT GOES OUT SIX ZERO.
LIVING TO FILE ITEM THREE AB
TWENTY THREE FIFTY FIVE.
WE NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND OF
THE BILL.
THIS IN MOTION AND A SECOND GRAY
AND CARILLO.
LOW THREE.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED.
TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE.
RATHER THAN MEN AND. WOMEN IN.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE AYE
BURKE AYE ROW. ROW NO CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE CHIU.
GRAY.
GRAY AYE MCCARTY.
CORDY I MELINDA'S.
MELINDA SNOW MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK I HOPE NO.
THE POLO.
THAT BILL PASSES SIXTY THREE.
LET'S FIX.
MILEY.
NOW.
AFRAID.
GOOD OF SIX WOMEN A FILE ITEM
SIX AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY EIGHT
A MOTION AND A SECOND.
MOVE THE BILL.
NAY MANY. AND SECOND ON FILE
ITEM.
SIX.
SEC.
GOOD SECOND.
TO PASS.
VERY.
DO PASSED.
TO THE FOR THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BURKE AYE FOR OUR AYE BURL.
BRUNO CARILLO. CARILLO AYE CHU.
GRAY.
HEY I MCCARTY.
CORDY I MELINDA'S MELINDA SNOW
MULLIN. MULLIN AYE QUIRK AYE
QUIRK AYE VOEPEL.
THAT DOES NOT SIXTY THREE MOVING
A FILE ITEM SEVEN AB TWENTY NINE
THIRTY TWO WILL LIFT THE CALL
AND CALL THE ABSENTEES.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S.
MELINDA'S AYE MULLIN.
LOW AND HIGH.
EIGHT.
THAT BILL THOSE OUT EIGHT TO ONE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NINE AB
TWENTY NINE NINETY NINE.
OVER.
A SECOND.
THE MOTION IS. TO PASSED ON
HOUSING WITH THE AMENDMENTS
BEING TAKEN AND HOUSING.
BURKE AYE BERG AYE.
BROUGH. BRO ARE ACRE REAL.
CARILLO AYE CHU GRAY.
GRAY AYE MCCARTY.
CORDY I MELINDA'S LINDA'S AYE
MULLIN. MULLIN AYE QUIRK NO
QUIRK NO. VOEPEL.
THE BILL I.
THAT DOES NOT EIGHT TO ONE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TEN AB
THIRTY FIFTY SEVEN WE HAVE A
MOTION.
AND A SECOND.
.
MCCORKLE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS STEVE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS.
BURKE AYE AYE BURKE ARE AYE
BROUGH.
MY BRO I CARILLO.
CREO I TO GRAY.
GRAY AYE MCCARTY.
CURRY I MELINDA'S.
MELINDA'S AYE MULLIN. MULLIN AYE
QUIRK.
I QUIRK I'VE OPPO.
HELLO.
THAT BILLS OUT NINE ZERO.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM AND FIVE AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SIX MISTER
DARCY WOULD YOU LIKE TO.
A MOVE THE BILL.
IF YOU. MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES A. ONE STOP BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THANK YOU FOR THE
WORK ON THE BILL. AB TWENTY
TEMPORE SIX CLARIFIES THE
STATE'S INTENT OF LAW ENABLING
TREASURE TAX COLLECTORS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO CONTINUE
THEIR TEXTILES PROCESS WITHOUT
BEING IMPAIRED IF A BANKRUPTCY.
IS FILED AFTER THE RIGHT OF
REDEMPTION HAS EXPIRED WITH WE
ARE TWO INDIVIDUALS CAMPBELL
WITH PRO COUNTING KATHY
GLOUCESTER WOULD LISTEN JUST
COUNTY TO UP. PROVIDE ANY.
TESTIMONY AND OR ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
RESPECT LAST RIVAL.
ALRIGHT UMP.
MY MICROPHONE OUT.
WITNESSES.
I'M INTO TOWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING TO OUR BILL.
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN. A GARCIA
MENTION THIS BILL IS ABOUT
CLARIFYING EXISTING LOUD YOU
STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATIONS THAT. ARE.
MY NAME IS KAREN VOCAL IN THE
TREASURE TAX COLLECTOR WITH
IMPERIAL COUNTY THANK YOU THANK
YOU. PANDAS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MENTIONED.
THE BUT THIS BILL IS TO CLARIFY
EXISTING OUGHT TO REFLECT
TODAY'S USE OF TECHNOLOGY AS A
KEY COMPONENT OF GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS.
THE TECH SELL MENU JUST.
TRIBUTE IT BY THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE REFERS TO
THE NEED TO STOP ATTACKS PHILIP
A BANKRUPTCY IS FILE PRIOR TO
THE EXPIRATION OF THE RIGHT OF
REDEMPTION. BUT DOES NOT
SPECIFICALLY STATE WHETHER THE
CELL MUST BE STOPPED IF THE
BANKRUPTCY.
IT'S FILED AFTER THE EXPIRATION
OF THE RIGHT OF REDEMPTION. THE
CONFLICT BETWEEN THE TWO RECENT
COURT DECISIONS HAS CREATED
SUBSTANTIAL CONCERNS FOR OUR
TREASURES AND TAX COLLECTORS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
TEXTILES NOW CONDUCTED VIA THE
INTERNET OVER SEVERAL DAYS OPEN
THE DOOR FOR AN ABUSE OF A LACK
OF CLARITY IN THE STATE LAW.
THIS CONFLICT WITH THEM PAIRED
OUR ABILITY TO COMPLEX TAX BILLS
WITHOUT THE RISK OF DEALING WITH
MORE LITIGATION EXPENSES.
THE BANKRUPTCY THAT ARE BEING
FILED ON THE EVE OF THE TAX ARE
ALREADY IMPAIRS OUR ABILITY.
TO OF THE COUNTIES TO SELL TAX
DEFAULT THE PROPERTY THING
BECAUSE SIGNIFICANT EXPENSES
THEREFORE MEANING THE RELEVANT
SECTIONS OF THE. BAR REVENUE AND
TAXATION CODE CLARIFIES THE
STATE'S INTENT OF THE LINE
ABEL'S TAX COLLECTORS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE TO CONTINUE THEIR TAX
SO PROCESS WITHOUT. BEING
IMPAIRED IF THE BANKRUPTCY IS
FILED AFTER THE RIGHT OF
REJECTION HAS EXPIRED THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THE
BILL AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT MAY HAVE.
ALRIGHT NEXT WITNESS.
I'M AYE HELLO I'M CATHY
GLOUCESTER AND I.
DON'T REALLY HAVE ANYTHING
OTHER TO AT OTHER WHO YOU WITH.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY THANK YOU.
.
AND I REALLY DON'T DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING ELSE TO ADD OTHER THAN
WHAT MS VOGEL ALREADY ADVISED TO
WHAT WE'RE REALLY LOOKING TO
GATHER HERE IS SOME CLARITY IN
THE LAW THAT REALLY DEFINES.
WHAT IT MEANS FOR SOMEONE TO LET
THE RIGHT OF REDEMPTION EXPIRE?
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT NAME AND
ORGANIZATION MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
OTHER MEMBERS SPOILER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
COUNTY TREASURES AND TAX
COLLECTORS SPORT CONCEPT ON THE
BILL APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
WORK ON IT. OR DRIVING THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
OF THOSE IN OPPOSITION.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MISS MELENDEZ.
THANK YOU.
I JUST I HAVE A QUESTION YOU
SHOULD YOU'RE TAKING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ARE YOU. I
JUST WANNA BE CLEAR WHAT THE
AMENDMENT IS BECAUSE THERE IS A
QUESTION RELATING TO LIABILITIES
SO SO THERE WERE THERE WERE
AMENDMENTS PUT FORWARD BY THE
COMMITTEE AND THERE AND THERE
WERE OTHER. A MEMBER LIKE HIM
WERE STILL JUST READ THEM.
SO THE AMENDMENTS AGREED TO BY
THE AUTHOR ARE TO DELETE THE
LIABILITY PROVISIONS SUBDIVISION
G..
EXPLICITLY ADDRESS INTERNET
SALES TAX THAT LASTS LONGER THAN
A DAY TO BETTER REFLECT THIS
BILL SEEN TEN.
THAT'S ON PAGE FOUR F.
AND THEN FINALLY A TECHNICAL
AMENDMENT TO LEAD AND NOT PAGE
FIVE G..
SO THOSE ARE THE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE.
SO.
SO YOU CONFIRM THAT YOU'VE
TAKEN THOSE AMENDMENTS.
AND.
YOU MAY CLOSE BACKREST VARIABLE.
THANK YOU.
SO THE CHAIR URGES TO PASS THIS
BILL.
THE ARGUMENTS ARE THE.
THE POINT IS THAT THERE IS A
QUESTION IN THE LAW.
IN THE OLD DAYS WHEN A.
.
WHEN THERE WAS A TAX LIABILITY.
IT WOULD GO TO THE COURTHOUSE
STEPS OR SOMETHING WE BE DONE
VERY QUICKLY NOW THINGS GO ON
THE INTERNET MAY TAKE SEVERAL
DAYS.
SO IN THE OLD DAYS WHO WAS CLEAR
YOU EITHER YOU COULD DECLARE
BANKRUPTCY BEFORE THE TAX
AUCTION.
BUT NOT.
DURING IT AND THAT WAS PRETTY
CLEAR. NOW THAT HE CAN GO FOR
THREE DAYS THE JUDGES SAID HE'S
NOT SURE WHAT THIS MEANS.
THE AUCTION HAS ENDED BUT IT
KINDA BEGAN AND SO WE'RE TRYING
TO GET CLARITY AND IN THIS CASE
TO BE GOING TO GO INTO
BANKRUPTCY. YOU HAVE TO DO IT
BEFORE.
THE.
.
NOT BEFORE THE AUCTION BEGINS
SAID SO IT'S A PRETTY SIMPLE
BILL TO CLEAN UP THE LAW. AND
CLEAN IT UP BUT I THINK AWAY
THAT'S APPROPRIATE. ARE FOR
EVERYONE SO WITH THAT.
MADAM SECRETARY OH WHEN THAT'S
DO PASS AS TO THE FLOOR AS
AMENDED. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL MACHINIST YOU AS
AMENDED BURKE.
BROUGH.
CARILLO. CREEL AYE CHU. GRAY.
GREY I AM MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
MELINDA'S
LINDA'S AYE MULLIN. MULLIN AYE
QUIRK AYE QUIRK I'VE AGO.
S. VERY GOOD SEVEN ZERO THAT
PASSES.
.
OKAY.
MISTER GALLAGHER OF COULD TO
SERGEANTS PLEASE GET MISTER
GALLAGHER HERE.
YES.
YEAH THAT THAT WOULD BE THE
FINAL BILL IN THE MEANTIME DO WE
HAVE MEMBERS HERO HAVEN'T VOTED
ON ANY OF THE PREVIOUS SPELLS.
IF SO. PLEASE ADD THEM.
WE JUST.
OKAY DOES IT LOOK LIKE WE HAVE
ANY ADD ONS UNLESS SOMEBODY IS
AWARE THAT THEY NEED TO ADD ON
SO. I WILL JUST WAIT MISTER
GALLAGHER PLEASE STAY HERE SO WE.
THE LAST BELL HEARD
.
SHE
MELINDA SUCH CHANGE.
NOT VOTING.
MULLIN THIS ITEM NUMBER TWO FROM
NOT VOTING TO KNOW
IN THIS CASE.
DISCUSSION.
CLOSE TO HER.
SURE.
THAT'S.
YEAH SURE.
MISTER CHAIR FOR ARAGON'S ITEM
NUMBER ONE.
THE BILL HAS PASSED.
CHIU I.
I AND NUMBER TWO THAT BILL HAS
PASSED CHIU.
CHIU I.
I AM HOWEVER THREE THAT BILL HAS
PASSED CHIU.
CHIU I.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR THAT BILL HAS
PASSED CHIU.
CHIU I.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE THAT BILL HAS
PASSED CHIU.
CHIU I.
I AM NUMBER SIX THAT BILL HAS
PASSED CHIU.
CHIU I.
ITEM NUMBER NINE.
THAT BILL HAS PASSED CHIU.
CHIU I.
AND ITEM NUMBER TEN THAT BILL
HAS PASSED.
CHU. CHU AYE.
LOOK WE WILL I WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE EVERYONE STAY HERE TILL
FOUR O'CLOCK.
WE HAVE AN INTERPRETER.
AND.
SO WE ARE I WANT TO GIVE MR
GALLAGHER A LITTLE BIT MORE TIME
I'VE AREAS VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
GALLAGHER.
WE DISPOSED OF OUR BUSINESS VERY
EFFICACIOUS SLING.
.
MOVE THE BILL.
FAR RIGHT YOU MAY START WHEN
READY MISTER GALLAGHER.
OKAY THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'D LIKE THANK YOU AND.
AND YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING ON
THIS BILL WITH ME AND I WOULD
LIKE TO TAKE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
ADD TO SHORT THE SUN STATE
SUNSET DATA FIVE YEARS.
TODAY I'M PROUD TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY NINE FORTY FIVE WHICH
PROMOTES JOB OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THE PHYSICALLY DISABLED. BY
OFFERING A TAX INCENTIVE FOR
BUSINESSES TO EMPLOY PERSONS
WITHOUT FUNCTIONAL HEARING.
DEAFENED HARD OF HEARING
INDIVIDUALS ARE NORMAL PEOPLE
WHO ARE CAPABLE OF CONTRIBUTING
TO CSUS
TO SOCIETY IN A MEN'S WAYS.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW I HAVE TO
DEAF BROTHERS AND.
AND THEY'RE BOTH THE MAYES
INDIVIDUALS IN THEIR OWN RIGHT.
BUT. I THINK A LOT OF TIMES.
.
IN SOCIETY.
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES ARE
STIGMATIZED TO SET THE SOCIALLY
OSTRACIZED.
AND BARRED FROM EMPLOYMENT.
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE SCARED OF
THEY DON'T KNOW HOW THEY WOULD
COMMUNICATE.
WITH MODERN TECHNOLOGY. IT'S SO
MUCH EASIER TO COMMUNICATE TO BE
ABLE TO.
YA WITH THE DEAF AND HARD OF
HEARING COMMUNITY.
BUT RIGHT NOW WE HAVE FORTY
EIGHT PERCENT OF THE DEAF AND
HARD OF HEARING PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA ARE NOT IN THE
WORKFORCE UNEMPLOYED.
THE PSYCHOLOGICAL EFFECTS OF
PROLONGED UNEMPLOYMENT
CORRELATES WITH SIGNIFICANT
INCREASES.
AN ANXIETY DEPRESSION LOSS OF
CONFIDENCE LOW SELF ESTEEM.
WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THE SEAS ARE CAPABLE PEOPLE WHO
CAN CONTRIBUTE TO OUR SOCIETY.
WE NEED TO REMOVE THE BARRIERS
AND THIS IS ONE WAY TO PRO IS TO
PROVIDE AN INCENTIVE.
AFTER BUSINESSES TO HIRE MORE.
DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING
INDIVIDUALS BUT REALLY.
INDIVIDUALS ACROSS THE BOARD
WITH DISABILITIES AND.
SO I IT WORKS WITH THE EXISTING
STATE INFRASTRUCTURE TO MINIMIZE
THE ADMINISTRATION COSTS AND
WILL ULTIMATELY BENEFIT.
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN LEFT BEHIND
BY SOCIETY.
BUT THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION AS MATT I DO HAVE A
WITNESS SUPPORT.
AS SHERRIE FARINA WITH NOR CAL.
CENTER ON.
DEAFNESS AND. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
BUT WHEN THE TIME COMES.
HELLO EVERYBODY MY NAME IS
SHERRY FARINA.
AND I'M THE CEO OF NOR HEALTH
SERVICES FOR THE DEAF AND HARD
OF HEARING.
SO WE COVER TWENTY FOUR NORTHERN
EASTERN COUNTIES.
AND. WE HAD AGENCIES WHAT WE
SERVICE PEOPLE FROM THE BIRTH
HIS TOMB A FEW WELL.
AND WE CONTRACT WITH VARIOUS.
GOVERNMENTAL AND AGENCIES
ENTERPRISES LIKE DEPARTMENT OF
REHAB FROM EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT CENTERS ANTI FF
DEATH ACCESS PROGRAMS.
AND ALTA REGIONAL CENTER. UP ALL
OF THOSE PROGRAMS PROVIDE
EMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE FOR A
VARIETY OF IN A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT WAYS OF ITS JOB
READINESS FOR PLACEMENT IF AND
TRAIN IT TRAINING AND THAT'S
NECESSARY FOR PLACEMENT.
AND LIKE HE JUST MENTIONED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. MENTIONED ON A
FORTY EIGHT PERCENT ON DEAF AND
HARD OF HEARING INDIVIDUALS.
AND IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
I'M.
IN THAT REPORT SAYS THE DEAF
PEOPLE EMPLOYEE EMPLOYMENT IN
THE IN THE UNITED STATES IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN IS LOW AND THE
LARGEST PERCENT IS FORTY SEVEN
PERCENT OF DEAF AND HARD OF
HEARING PEOPLE ARE NOT IN THE
EMPLOYMENT.
I AM NOT EMPLOYED AND SOME AND
OUR SPELLS THE STUDENTS ARE WITH
EARLY RETIREMENT.
BUT WE KNOW THAT THERE IS A
LARGE PERCENT OF THEM THAT ON SS
I AND SSD I. RELIANT ON THAT FOR
DEAF PEOPLE WHO WORK FULL TIME
AND ALSO WITH NAY REPORT NATURAL
AND IN ANNUAL AND CRAM WHICH IS
SAYING SIMILAR TO I'M HEARING
INDIVIDUALS AND POPULATION.
SO EDUCATIONAL GOAL ACADEMICS
AND.
I WOULD SAY AND THEY ADVANCED
DEGREES AT CETERA AT THIS HELPS
THEM TO ADD RECEIVE MORE JOB
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EMPLOYMENT.
SEWED PEOPLE PEOPLE THAT ARE
DEAF WHAT IS IT WITH A
DISABILITIES AND ALSO OTHER
DISABILITIES HAVE ADDITIONAL
CHALLENGES. AND MOST OF THE THAT
MOST THE BARRIERS THAT WE
FORESEE OUT THERE IN THE
COMMUNITIES HAD ISSUE.
AND SO THAT PREVENTS EMPLOYERS
FIVE HIRING DEAF PEOPLE.
BUT AND THOSE THAT DO HIRE THEM
AND ARE IN CONSTANT CONTACT WITH
TAX CONSEQUENCE TACT IN THE WEEK
PROVIDE CONTINUOUS SUPPORT SO
THAT THEY CAN HIRE MORE DEAF
INDIVIDUALS. LIKE FAT ACTS.
I SAFE WAY TARGETS.
AMAZON A GOOD WILL ETCETERA.
AND SO THAT WE PROVIDE A TAX EX
OR THERE ARE TAX INCENTIVES FOR
THEM INCENTIVES FOR THEM TO PUT
THE TO REDUCE THE VARIOUS FOR
DEAF PEOPLE. IN THEIR EMPLOYMENT
SO WE ASK FOR YOU TO SUB SUPPORT
THE BILL.
AND ASSEMBLY BILL TO NINE FOUR.
BY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL INSISTS.
A MENTOR MEMBERS PRICE DOUGHERTY
WITH KP PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF
OF HEARING HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
OF CALIFORNIA. WHERE THOSE
PRACTITIONERS THAT FIT FURNISH A
JUST AND SELL YOU HEARING AIDS?
MERE INDULGENCE BRIEFLY.
TO TELL HER STORY WITH ME IS
JOSH JOCELYN A DAILY ON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JOCELYN DE
LEóN AND I AM CURRENTLY OF THE
PATIENT CARE COORDINATOR. AT
COURT PLACE HEARING CENTER IN
PETALUMA.
PART PLEASE HEARING CENTER IS A
COMPREHENSIVE AUDITORY HEALTH
PROVIDER THAT FURNISHES
EXTENSIVE SERVICES. AROUND
HEARING HEALTH CARE.
I HAVE WORKED AT PARK PLEASE
HEARING CENTER SINCE JULY TWENTY
SEVENTEEN.
AT AGE SEVEN I WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH HEARING LOSS AND REFERRED
TO USE YES UP. FOR FOLLOW UP
CARE.
I WAS PROVIDED WITH.
WHITE NEXT BEHIND THE EAR
HEARING AIDS
BUT FREQUENTLY DID NOT USE THEM
BECAUSE OTHER CHILDREN AT MY
SCHOOL. WOULD BULLY ME AND MAKE
FUN OF ME.
THROUGHOUT THAT TIME I.
DIDN'T WEAR MY HEARING AIDS DUE
TO THE FEAR OF JUDGMENT.
.
SOCIAL LIFE.
I.
.
PRETTY MUCH THE NOT WHERE
HEARING AIDS FOR THE AGE OF TEN
TO.
NINETEEN.
IN SPITE OF THIS I GRADUATED
FROM COSTS ARE GOING TO HIGH
SCHOOL IN TWO THOUSAND TEN.
I GOT MY MEDICAL ASSISTANT
DIPLOMA IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
IN RECENTLY GRADUATED FROM SANTA
ROSA JUNIOR COLLEGE LAST YEAR.
STILL BECAUSE OF MY HEARING
LOSS OF FACE BARRIERS IN FINDING
EMPLOYMENT.
IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN I
WORKED AS A MEDICAL ASSISTANT IN
AN ENDOCRINOLOGIST OFFICE.
THE SUPERVISOR THAT WAS WORKING
THERE BEFORE.
BEFORE.
I START WORKING THERE.
SHE KNEW ABOUT MY HEARING LOSS
IN SHE ACCOMMODATED ME AND SHE
TOLD EVERYONE IN THE OFFICE.
ABOUT MY HEARING LOSS AND
EVERYONE WAS VERY UNDERSTANDING.
.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY WE HAD A NEW
SUPERVISOR COME IN. AND REPLACED
HER SPOT.
WHEN I WENT UP TO HER AND TOLD
HER ABOUT THE HEARING LOSS SHE'D
MADE ME FEEL VERY UNCOMFORTABLE.
SHE STARTED TELLING PATIENTS AND.
SOMEHOW I GUESS SHE FELT SORRY
FOR ME BUT.
SHE WOULD ISOLATE ME FROM MY
DUTIES DIDN'T WANT ME
COMMUNICATING WITH PATIENTS
DIDN'T WANT ME. ADMINISTRATING
INJECTIONS OR THE STUFF THAT A
MEDICAL ASSISTANT DOES.
.
IN.
BECAUSE OF HER I BASICALLY.
I QUIT MY JOB AND DECIDED.
TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL FULL TIME.
AND THAT'S WHERE I STARTED GOING
TO SANTA ROSA JUNIOR COLLEGE.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN.
IS WHEN I TOOK THE DECISION. OF
GETTING HEARING AIDS BECAUSE MY
HEARING LOSS WAS GETTING WORSE.
AND THAT'S WHERE I FOUND PART
PLEASE HEARING CENTER.
AND PHYLLIS BYRNE WAS
AUDIOLOGISTS AT THAT TIME. AND
SHE TESTED ME AND.
MY HEARING LOSS HAD NOT CHANGED
SINCE I WAS EIGHT.
I HAVE MODERATE SENSORINEURAL
HEARING LOSS BILATERALLY. AND I
AM CURRENTLY WEARING STARKEY AYE
AYE SEES.
.
DENNIS TOOK OVER PART POLICING
CENTER IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN.
SO AS A PATIENT I WOULD GO GO TO
MY FOLLOW UP APPOINTMENTS.
AND HE LET ME KNOW THAT THERE
WAS ALWAYS A JOB OPENING FOR ME
AND THAT HE WAS WILLING TO HELP
ME.
HE KNEW THAT AS A YOUNG PERSON
THREE LOSS I COULD COMMUNICATE
WITH PATIENTS IN A DIFFERENT WAY
AND UNDERSTAND THEIR NEEDS
BETTER.
I AM NOW THEIR PATIENT CARE
COORDINATOR AND ACTUALLY WORKING
TOWARDS GETTING MY LICENSE TO
BECOME A HEARING AID TO SPONSOR.
AN HEARING INSTRUMENT SPECIALIST.
I'M LUCKY THAT I WORK IN A PLACE
THAT SEES ME AS A STRENGTH TO
THEIR BUSINESS AND TO THEIR
PATIENTS.
BUT MANY OTHER PEOPLE WITH
HEARING LOSS OR WHO ARE DEAF OR
NOT.
AB TWENTY NINE FORTY FIVE WOULD
HELP OTHER BUSINESSES AND
EMPLOYERS UNDERSTAND THAT WE ARE
STRONG EMPLOYEES AND CAN BE PART
OF THE TEAM.
FOR THESE REASONS I ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT AB TWENTY NINE FORTY
FIVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING AND HEARING AND COST
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS.
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MISTER MULLIN.
THANK YOU OF MADAME CHAIR JUST
THE THANK YOU TO MISTER
GALLAGHER FEAR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE OF SOMEBODY WHO WEARS
HEARING AIDS AND.
HAS SENSITIVITY ON THIS ISSUE IT
LOW TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
OF I HAVEN'T ALREADY AND DOWN.
VERY PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE BILL
AND GRATEFUL FOR YOUR EFFORTS.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. HOPE MISTER
ABOUT.
I HAVE ONE COMMENT.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
MISTER DOLLAR AYE TO WOULD LIKE
TO THANK YOU FOR THIS BILL I
ACTUALLY SUFFER MOST WILL
RELEASE I SUFFER FROM HEARING
LOSS AS A RESULT OF AN ACCIDENT
SO.
I DO KNOW THE DIFFICULTIES OF
THOSE FACE WITH HEARING LOSS SO.
WITH THAT WE DO HAVE OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS I THE
ONLY AMENDMENT IS TO SHORTEN THE
CENTS A PERIOD OF FIVE YEARS.
THING YOU'VE ACCEPTED THAT
CORRECT YES THAT'S CORRECT RIGHT
MISS HIGHLY CALL THE ROLL THE
MOTION IS DO PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE.
BURKE EYEBROW. CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE CHU. CHU AYE GRAY.
GRAY AYE MCCARTY.
CORDY I MELINDA'S. LINDA'S AYE
MULLIN. MULLIN AYE QUIRK LOGO.
THE BILL THAT'S EIGHT ZERO.
THAT BILLS OUT EIGHT ZERO.
WE LISTEN.
EARLY ON YOU ARE INVESTING ON
ONE.
THE FILE AT HOME HAVING A FILE
ITEM CAUGHT FIVE GOING ABSENTEES.
FOR AYE BURKE AYE.
PHYLLIS ONE AWAY FROM MR QUIRK
HE'S ONLY MISSING ON ONE.
OKAY HE DIDN'T TELL ME THAT.
WARY TURNED